したがって、私が示す単語のバイナリグラフィックをプルアップした場合
、
またはピッチ
が低く
始まり、塩の上に落ちてから、粒子全体で低いままであることが
わかります。ただし
、このグラフィックは
ピッチ事故の家族を示すためのものであることに注意してください。
通常の英語の辞書のように、isolのピッチアクシデントパターンは
、各リストに音声のスペルがあることが多いため
、アクセントがその単語のどこにあるかを示す
スペルは、
正確なスペクトログラフではありませんが、学習者に伝えます
通常、話すときにアクセントが落ちる
ので、これ
も話者が怒っているか、幸せか、落ち着いているかどうかを質問しているかどうかを
反映していません。また、
前述のデフォルトの
ピッチの段階的な低下も反映していません。 したがって、ネイティブ
スピーカーがこれ
を通常の非質問フレーズとして言う場合、
このフレーズの実際のピッチは
おそらくこのようになります。
前のレッスンでこのフレーズを使用したので、このフレーズの
録音です。ネイティブの録音ビンゴのスペクトログラフ
を、
バイナリピッチアクセントグラフィックと比較して確認しましょう。実際の
スペクトログラフ
は、ピッチアイシャのごくわずかな緩やかな低下を
示します。
自然な非常に穏やかなピッチの低下。
これが
、耳の良い非常に少数の日本人学習者
が、ピッチ
のわずかな低下を聞くことについてよく話す理由です。
これらの学習者は、
ピッチのわずかな低下を聞く可能性がありますが、これ
は反映されていません。 この種のバイナリ
ピッチチェックとグラフィックス、つまり
bang aiのバイナリピッチアクショングラフィックは次のようになります
が、この単語の実際のスペクトログラフ
は通常
このようになり
、この単語のネイティブレコーディングが発生します。
前のレッスンでも使用されたので
、ネイティブレコーディングのスペクトログラフがどのように表示されるかを見てみましょう。
ピッチに関連する現象のごくわずかな低下
一部の学習者は、この中高パターンをこの中高パターンと誤解することがよくあり
ます